julianne hesketh smoked cigarettes for
more than three decades she recently
quit taking up vaping instead what was
the thing for you that made you finally
want to quit smoking i'm disabled um so
my my funds are limited um
so it became
i would go without food
to buy tobacco
and you've got to think
it's not right
the government wants fewer than five
percent of people in england to smoke by
2030 but that would require drastic
action
one of their advisors suggests the age
at which you can buy tobacco products
should be increased every year
eventually no one would be able to
purchase them legally
two-thirds of people who smoke are
likely to die as a result of it and
along the way a large proportion of
their income will have been spent on
smoking
we estimate that if we can make smoking
obsolete over two million adults will be
brought out of poverty and one million
children will be brought out of poverty
so the implications of smoking at the
moment to health and wealth are very
significant
the review also says more money needs to
go into promoting e-cigarettes as a
safer alternative to tobacco although
it's not risk-free
over recent years there have been
several efforts to make smoking harder
and less appealing since 2002 cigarette
packets have come with health warnings
and as of 2008 they featured graphic
pictures of the side effects of smoking
in 2015 shops were banned from
displaying tobacco products and a year
later cigarettes in the uk had to be
sold in plain brown packaging
if the age limit goes up further these
18 year olds soon wouldn't be able to
buy cigarettes
i think it would benefit a lot because
you see children and
they're influencing other children to
come and smoke and
they're seeing their adults smoke so
they want to smoke and it's like
it's just getting out of them you're
going to get people that will manage to
get it from different places and they
are going to sell it to younger years
they will do it it's a fact i know it's
going to happen it's one of them things
like they've just got to accept and it's
just going to make that that's what i'm
saying it's going to make everything 10
times worse because it generally will
but i don't think they've took that into
consideration
banning tobacco for future generations
might be a step too far for the
government right now but as the strain
on the nhs and people's finances
intensifies many want more to be done to
tackle this expensive and deadly habit
becky cottrell sky news saint helens